pour que le suédois michael rymer est un
successeur au palmarès en 2020 il faut
que plusieurs conditions soient réunies
qui dépendent entre autres des
négociations en cours entre la
fédération française de tennis
la mairie de paris et l'atp qui gère le
circuit professionnel
initialement prévue à partir du 20
septembre le tournoi parisien pourraient
commencer le 27 en concurrence directe
avec orléans qui seraient privés de la
participation des cent vingt meilleurs
mondiaux est donc obligé de trouver une
nouvelle date dans un calendrier déjà
très encombré la tp étant très attentif
au sort de l'open d'orient comme vous le
savez le planned orient et plus gros
challenger mondial et donc ils m'ont
contacté plusieurs fois pour me dire que
si c'était le cas ils envisagent de
transférer l'open d'orléans
plus tard dans la saison
vraisemblablement en haut rang mais pour
l'instant rien est officiel
dans le meilleur des cas l'open pourrait
se dérouler fin novembre
mais le tennis professionnel se prépare
aussi à l'éventuelle annulation de tous
les tournois internationaux
si des quarantaines sont imposées aux
voyageurs dans cette hypothèse
orléans a proposé un plan b validé par
la fédération française accueillir tous
les meilleurs joueurs français comme
tsonga déjà présent l'année dernière où
gaël monfils et quelques-uns des
meilleurs mondiaux résidant en france
il viendrait à orléans pour préparer la
prochaine saison et avoir la garantie de
disputer plusieurs matches de haut
niveau
si un gaël monfils venait à l'open
d'orléans
voudrait on voudrait être sûr qu'il
fasse plusieurs matchs donc l'idée c'est
de proposer quatre poules de quatre
joueurs et donc ils feraient chacun tous
ces sept joueurs frais chacun au moins
trois matches et samedis dimanches demi
finales finale
dans mon esprit c'est un vrai tournoi il
n'est pas question que ce soit une
exhibition dans cette hypothèse
orléans propose aussi d'accueillir la
même semaine les quatre meilleures
joueuses françaises
mais à cette heure personne ne peut
exclure le pire des scénarios
l'interdiction des rassemblements
sportifs à l'automne si l'épidémie
perdure en cas d'annulation orléans
pourrait bénéficier d'une partie de l'
enveloppe de 35 millions d'euros prévus
par la fédération pour soutenir toute la
famille du tennis français